grund zu [ __ ] penis steif hast du auch
was wir haben ist nicht nur geschaut
beide teams steigt und wenn die beide
bereiche sind dann dachte das ist dann
musst du einfach reinklicken
bmh herzlich willkommen zu meinem
heutigen video heute zusammen mit riese
unser erstes gemeinsames wir kennen uns
schon so lange jetzt wenn noch nie video
zusammen gemacht du hast schon heftig
aber irgendwie ist es ja auch so du hast
es ja immer dein musikkanal und jetzt
hast du den royal kanal und der immer
noch übrig und bin lustig und habe jetzt
gesagt und die solidarität zu sein und
sagt ja das jetzt mal gerne also der
nachricht jeder warum hast du den sogen
mittlerweile finde ich es voll von ihr
die sache ist mit diesen dingen warum
habe ich mein kanal so genannte starke
ich mich seit wir spielen heute ihr
habt's wahrscheinlich noch ein titel
gesehen stadland spaßt oder stadland
youtuber oder was auch immer
und ich will sagen wir überlegen ein
paar kategorien und dann beginnt der
spaß beginnt der spaß bis ich mich ja
was sind die managerin mit müssten stadt
und land als erstes haben nehmen wir mal
sehen wir mal schon da und dann ab jetzt
machen wir noch quatsch wie wär's mit
gericht ach so was zum essen genau ich
dachte jetzt kann ich mir auch was
aussehen wenn ich gut argumentieren kann
dass das ein gericht sein könnte
theoretisch kann alles im gericht sein
so aber alles was essbar ist ja aber es
sollte ja schon sich anhören oder das
entscheiden wir dann im 1 wir werden
dann argumentieren gleich vorwand für
sex brauchen vorwand wird er halt so so
das warst du im anderen sagt weshalb das
jetzt eine gute idee wäre miteinander zu
schlafen jetzt einfach grund zu [ __ ]
genau also grund zu finden bedeutet du
gehst wie man so sagt
heute wäre schon echt gut wird weißt du
wer freunde oder seid ihr video denn und
da sagst du ja mit einem wort mit einem
wort die es machen ureinwohnern immer
noch
anderes wort für packen ok jaja anderer
ausdruck für kmu grund dich also die
jeweils anderen zu deponieren
was für ein grund ist dass ich dich die
aronia genau diese kategorie grund zu
der abonniert stopp und ich musste was
gleich ich hatte das schon mit vergessen
perfekt leute das war heute das ist was
schauen ich habe zwei sachen hey ag
stadt habe ich habe scheiße ich habe
auch hamburg und ich dachte mir kommen
auch so haben weil bestimmt dass du auch
an brücken ja das heißt es gibt zehn
punkte ja sagen wir zehn er richtig habe
ich nichts ich habe haar verkürzte
verkürzt das heißt weg 20 ministers
grund zu [ __ ] habe ich haaren nasa
polen tochter und das doch kein grund zu
viel auch wenn du so ein richtiger
suchen tochter sie ist die klicken was
das wort verfahren das im sinne von wenn
der partner die haare nass sodass das
muss jetzt erklären ich habe neulich ich
sage nicht mehr aber ich habe neulich
mit einer youtube gesprochen die mir
genau das gesagt hat die mir genauer
gesagt hat so wenn der partner so also
außerirdischen kommentaren macht sie
schon ein bisschen gailbach wasser ja
okay dann kriegst du den punkt und
tochter leben gebe ich mir mal keinen
punkt sagte ok anderes wort kann ich
habe einfach viel zu klein ein jahr
einen hineindrücken jahr ziemlich und
grund zu definieren wenn du sara nuru
soja das verstehe ich ja du hast suchen
tochter und so hat das eine zielt ja
nicht von daher
stopp schlechte kunde also statt ich
musste auch nicht überlegen die
kanzlerin und wieso präsenz oder so es
gibt ja schon statt
und dann das paris die werden es ist ja
nicht nur deutschland nachdem er dort
gar nicht okay dann habe ich gericht nun
kommen und hannah al arabija da bist du
kultiviert weiter grund zu finden die so
20 wenn man etwas andere werden
vielleicht ist er für penis steif
hast du auch was wir haben genau so ist
hast du echt nicht nur geschaut
ddp wir machen 100 punkten also packen
wir das pressen ich habe klettern aber
es ist eine ideologie ich vieles aber
wenn wir das locker nicht genau was du
mir eine fast banal
ich habe zwar ein neues wort ausgeprägt
dass die 20 punkte kriegsgrund zu
deponieren penis draußen es in einem
video etwa dein penis oder draußen
hängen gelassen hast dann sagt jeder das
recht unangenehme erlebnis mal sehen was
so werde ich hab perverser content für
kinder ja verstehe ich das ist auf jeden
fall ein grund zu der nächste buchstabe
a
doch etwas verlieren zu [ __ ] bei mir
ist anderes wort für da sehen wir
gemeinsam fertig geworden ist jetzt gibt
es einiges zu hören sollte abonniert
darf dann an dieser stelle einfach mal
wirklich abonniert auf diesem kanal ist
ein hervorragender kanal da kann auch
einfach mal ab und die glocke drücken
kann man auch da freut sich doch der
maxi ich habe in meinem leben noch nie
gesagt
dann habe ich das jetzt für dich gesagt
die glocke denn der algorithmus zeigt
euch sonst die die videos nicht und eine
sache die ich wirklich sagen wollte
jackmann instagram account ab da habe
ich nämlich das ist ein foto mit meinem
auto gepostet mir heute bestimmt alle
wissen das für den autofahrer deshalb
hat check in ist er bekommt ab und ein
bisschen was für ein auto bauen lassen
1000 euro ok also statt wir machen warum
schweiz bern leitet das gericht
bratkartoffeln 320 grund zu [ __ ]
bikini-fotos ist wenn ich bin ja heute
so auch instagram habe keine ahnung was
dann sage ich hey schatz ich bin jetzt
geil weil ich habe mir an
die frauen dafür erhöht werden was hast
du ich habe beine breit denn die beine
bereit sind dann dahin blass ist dann
musst du einfach rein
ok anderes wort für packen einen braunen
raus drücken aber das sind eben frauen
darüber hinaus und träumt er ich gehe
ganz kurz und braun raus schon mal vor
glaube jeder würde sieht man würde er
beim herausdrücken sagen oder was mich
aber das ist trotzdem gut 21 punkte
macht das wort bekannt ist breit
bombenabwurf breit bombenabwurf also
absoluter schwachsinn ich hab da so das
geld aber ich wusste auch was du x 10.3
bombenabwurf grund zu deponieren
belästigen
ich wollte das land belästigend
minderjährigen gegenüber welcher
irgendjemanden bestimmt
könnte ja grund zu deponieren beinahe
umgekommen also quasi eine nahtod
erfahrung die ein grundsätzlich alles
was man macht in frage stellen lässt und
nicht von youtube in der richtung habe
ich noch nicht überlegt dass du dann
sozusagen ich habe immer überlegt was
macht derjenige den ich die abonnieren
möchte und du hörst brand was dann
geschah und da indústria tor davon und
deswegen der bundes und leute vorletzte
runde leute jetzt wird es noch einmal
richtig spannend
stock wo nur einbußen kag wort hier
kannst du sagst das ist auf jeden fall
das zitat des heutigen videos ruhe ist
ein kack dort wo man gegen explodiert
nicht so viel mitgemacht irgendwie stopp
ich habe zwei sachen okay statt wie
nichts ich habe kein gericht welchen
neisser dir du bist so viel kultiviert
als ich so ristow städte aus aller welt
und so gericht hatte so was ich habe
pommes bratkartoffeln bratwurst
in der lage große klicken dazu gehöre so
da hab ich nicht was ich habe roadbike
outdoor sex es ist nicht der grund zu
[ __ ] oder ok ja das recht dass ich
glaube es ist mir egal
andere packen quetsche posten
ich habe vermutet klitschkos natürlich
optisch rekurs quetsch wursten kleine
gründlich zu deponieren hab ich nix ich
habe quengeln wenn so jemand ernst als
dass sich beschwert über all das ist das
ein guter punkt letzte runde krass
gesagt machen wir drücken
das gegenstück sonics bvt es zu schwer
ich fange aber einfach mittendrin an ok
egal waren wir einfach aber ich habe das
ganz lustig bei grund zu [ __ ] und sein
grund zu deponieren ist es bei mir
austauschbar rechnen könnte es beides
bei bildung nehmen bei mir nie erträumen
osnabrück gerichte sind schon so wie vom
gericht ich habe oliven mit brot essen
gewesen
ich sag mal ja wir sind eure lieben
eingefallen so und zu schicken da habe
ich offene bluse was auch ein grund zu
telefoniert für manche werden und wenn
jemand ständig auch eine bluse man hat
dann sollte das will ich mich nicht
gegen die ich habe oben ohne
ja er ist also ein anderes wort für
klappen habe ich nicht klappt ordentlich
abschließen ist das legal ist
grund zu deponieren an ihren also wenn
derjenige onaniert hat in dem video was
auch wieder ein grund zu finden wäre
wenn ich sage ich habe gerade angefangen
zu onanieren jetzt bin ich geil geworden
und weiß irgendwie vieles ja das ist
natürlich recht
es gibt 50 punkten in der tat höchst
punkte habe ich gerade nachgeschaut und
studieren ordnungswidrigkeit mit dem
leon der schwer aber man merkt bei uns
beiden charakter und die ganze zeit so
über echte für gefunden ist draußen
onanie aber penis steif hat mir schon
mal beides stimmt also lasst uns ganz
kurz berechnen wie viele punkte wir
haben meinen berechnungen zufolge habe
ich 123000 484 punkte und tutow auch ja
ich auch noch habe ich gerade auch okay
das war ein spannendes spiel ist ein
kopf an kopf rennen wenn ihr sehen wollt
dass wir so etwas noch mal machen wir
das
max so dieses dieses format noch mal
macht dann gibt es ein daumen nach oben
weil dann weiß er mag dass er das noch
mal machen sollte vielleicht mit mir
fest mit mit wem man ach das ist ja was
schön ist ganz genau lasst doch einfach
gerne ein like da wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder check unbedingt
krise abgenommen haben auch ein video
auf seinem kanal gemeint sagt genau das
wird auch kommen in zwei wochen kommt
dann immer perfekt dann sehen wir uns
macht's gut